movie made me hungry
the green inferno so the premise of the
green inferno is a group of these
college kids get together in this
activist group so they all go to the
Amazon to protest bulldozing that are
happening over there and then their
plane goes down in the Amazon in the
middle of nowhere and they're like oh
we're in trouble and his group and
natives darts them all knocks them out
brings them back to their village and to
have them for dinner in a manner of
speaking because they are a tribe of
cannibals so the green inferno is
brought to us by writer director Eli
Roth and like most Eli Roth movies as
movies a complete Gore no Gore fest with
bad actors playing shitty characters and
if you like Eli Roth's movies and that's
what you're in for you're gonna love
this movie because this movie has a lot
of what you love I'm gonna get to what I
liked about the movie first of all
admittedly
this movie is very tension film right
out the gate when they're captured by
this tribe they slice up one dude they
cook them they eat him so you know what
these people are in for and after that
it's a matter of time you're like oh God
wanted to come home and they're coming
back oh they're gone they're at a point
I looked around everyone I was doing it
to I was biting my nails and I looked
bunch of people just biting their nails
and I was like nobody's effective in
that right and if that's all you crave
in your movie you have hit pay dirt and
the tribe was actually they looked neat
you know they had bones coming out of
their noses rapping already just look at
these cannibals you're like costume
designs very I like it it's just
interesting looking to me other than
that though it's just basic Eli Roth
[ __ ] from the beginning of the movie I
was watching the actors interact knows
like you people look like you act like
you're in porn this is porn with none of
the sex porn you have Gore porn say what
give credit to the buildup in this movie
because the build-up takes half the mood
takes them half the movie to actually
get to the cannibals killing them and I
want to give credit to that and what a
great buildup but no the characters are
shitty and they're stupid and they don't
matter and they're portrayed by bad
actors so the whole thing is just wasted
and the movie has awkward-ass humor in
it like this one girl they're all caged
up and they're gonna die she's like I'm
really sick they're like yeah we all are
just like no I need a bathroom and she
goes to the corner of the cell and she
explosively just shits
and it's executing this like he has
supposed to be funny kind of way and
you're like that's awkward if it's
supposed to be funny but I was giving
credit I was like maybe they use it
throw it at the natives to freak them
out splat him in the face and that's how
they escape who knows how you're going
to get through this thing but no one
ever touches on that again they never
address it it just happens for the sake
of awkward ass humor it's kind of like
this one girl dies and the [ __ ] of
the group is in the corner he's just
beaten off like what are you doing he's
like you have to clear your mind
situations like this is the best way to
do it I was like this is stupid
I mean there is relevance to the whole
like eight-pound one out and you're a
lot more common you can think clearer
you do that if you're say online and
you're about to buy the pornhub twerking
ass yeah go pound one out come back see
if you really still want that thing in
this particular situation it was just
awkward and weird and it was meant to be
funny I know people are gonna try to be
pseudo intellectual about I was like
it's just betraying how if you strip
with humanity and put someone in
situation like that we're all just
animals who react sexually to violence
no don't give the movie that credit it's
not like that this is basic Eli Roth
stuff I want to be completely
transparent with you guys I really don't
get Eli raw I just don't get the whole
thing you hear how Eli Roth is this
genius he's some sort of horror master
and in the end his movies have shitty
actors and bad characters and they're
just gorgeous and I don't get how he's
this famous it's one of the things like
Eli Roth is famous because people set
Eli Roth is famous and that just now has
to be no one can actually give me a good
reason why he's this famous he is a good
business mind and I'll say that about
him all right I get that aspect the dude
is a producer on a lot of [ __ ] he
produces a lot of things he has his
fingers in a lot of pots great but
genius film maker guys in the end the
green inferno is exactly what you think
the green inferno is going to be it is
the Eli Roth fest in everything that
that actually entails if you love eli
roth movies here you go you're going to
love it so you should go see it if he's
not really your thing and i'll let you
know i've never been a fan of the dude
and this is not one me over to his side
the grinning for now i'm not gonna
remember in t-minus a couple days ya
already forgot all right guys are the
green inferno have you seen it what did
you think about it what do you think of
eli roth in general not being a dick
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more